like yeah I guess let's go into this
rent strike cuz this is gonna be a whole
nother you know April first only by
getting here by the time you are
watching this it is April 1st and I'm
going to issue a an apology not an
apology what's the right word my empathy
my sympathy my condolences to all of you
who are on the internet on April 1st it
is the worst day it is the day that hell
comes to earth from him because the
internet is full of morons who think
they're funny saying stupid things not
much like bro it's not funny
shut up April Fool's is stupid really
it's just it's so annoying it's like you
ever you ever have a friend who's not
funny who constantly makes jokes and
you're like yes everybody has those
friends it's April Fool's but anyway but
anyway the internet turns into that
friends you didn't click this video
because you were concerned about April
Fool's you were concerned about rent
strike so this is story from The
Associated Press rent strike idea is
gaining steam during coronavirus crisis
and I mean yeah what do you expect
people to do supposed to do if you have
no job and yeah and it's because the
government shut you down and you just be
like well I guess I'm homeless or no
this is it this is a struggle because
landlords do a job right as much as many
of the leftist try to argue landlord
isn't a job it is they maintain
properties they pay taxes they the
handle regulations they get inspected
they do a lot of work if your roofs leak
and guess what Atlanta's got to fix it
they maintain the properties and then
guess what when you leave in a year they
have to maintain the property for the 30
year mortgage they have on it so yeah
it's work that has to be done people
have to be hired for this do you think
they can sign up for unemployment also
they know millions of business loans
there was actually a viral meme that was
for landlords it was an FAQ for
landlords like what to do and it was
like if I'm a landlord in my property
you know my tenants aren't paying rent
what do I do this it congratulations
you've gone from a rental management
company to a property investment firm
you now have investment property that
will be accruing value of the next you
know however many years and you don't
have to worry about direct income and
then the next question was like but I
rely on this income to pay my employees
and not congratulations your employees
and you can now apply for government
benefits
the same as everyone else who's
struggling and it's like it was funny I
get it but it's like so many people on
the left just seem to think that
property is a magic box that can just be
impenetrable unless last forever they
don't realize that damage has to be
repaired and pipes have to be fixed did
you know that in Chicago in the older
buildings in the winter you have to run
the water non-stop
or just a little time a little tiny bit
the water has gone out doesn't freeze
and burst the pipes yeah
and tenants don't care so and a lot of
these buildings on the south side the
pipes freeze up in the winter and then
burst and stop working and then the
landlords have to come in and fix and
the tenants don't care not my problem
not my building I mean you're right and
then you're in trouble as the landlord
because you have to fix it every time
yeah so yeah well right now we have
millions of people Helen let me just
read you from The Associated Press they
say with millions of people suddenly out
of work and rent due at the first of the
month some tenants are vowing to go in a
rent strike until the corona virus
pandemic subsides New York Boston LA San
Francisco and st. Louis are among many
cities that have temporarily banned
evictions but advocates for the strike
are demanding that rent payments be
waived not delayed for those in need
during the crisis the rent strike idea
has taken root in parts of North America
and as far away as London now here's the
here's the struggle III I empathize if
you've lost your job because the
government forced a shutdown then why
should you now be homeless because the
government is mandating you don't go to
work at the same time it's not the
landlord's fault
the landlord's have to pay their income
have to maintain the properties and hire
people so how does it make sense that
you're demanding the government tell you
you can't pay someone for a service and
put it this way let's say you went I
demand
we're gonna go on a food strike I should
not have to pay for any food foods more
important than shelter right well
actually I don't know if that's true a
shelter might be more important than
food because you can go a month without
food but you can't go that long without
shelter anyway the point is yeah food's
a necessity what if people went on food
strike and demanded that Walmart give
them all free food what's the difference
I mean it's like shelter last
longer I guess and it's all gonna be
maintained and paid for yeah I don't
know this is an issue though yeah what
do we do I feels like the government
needs to be helping them out as well
it's like it's there
they're the ones who said we got to
close it all down yeah there's no doubt
but they bailed out they gave 25 million
to that school who then doesn't yeah
Theater Kennedy Center then they
furloughed offer everybody yeah
it's like yeah nice job I don't know but
but so there's a funny libertarian meme
it's like people line up to gleefully
accepting checks are gleefully line up
to receive their own money back from the
government yeah it's like yeah that's
the funny thing about like tax refunds -
it's like people like yeah I'm getting a
big refund and it's like is your money
to begin with like saving it yeah you
shouldn't you should have had it but I
don't know I don't have ideal this
problem in people I think there's gonna
be food riots I think there's gonna be
rent riots there's gonna be there's
gonna be fights because look man the
same feeling these people have for how
they can't pay rent and so they're
demanding support what do you think
these you know management companies are
to be saying about their employees well
the landlord's won't be able to pay the
mortgage like you're just okay there's
this further up the stream so like the
place the apartments in New York where
we're at back in the day on in beds were
in Bushwick
we're in Bushwick yeah they there was a
company not that's time that's died it
was a company that maintained those
buildings and a bunch of other buildings
so they took care of all the tenants
they weren't great but whatever you know
they ran a company what happens when
those bosses are like dude if you don't
pay I can't pay my employees what do
they do
I think it should just keep falling up
and all the way up to the banks because
they got the money
yeah but money is a representation of
like energy and labor like so you can
only do it so many times we keep
printing money then it just we're
borrowing from ourselves in the future
all everyone's savings will be wiped out
like you you've got a hundred bucks now
saved in the bank it's gonna be worth 20
bucks yeah because we were just dumping
money like crazy the economy causing
rapid inflation so is that what we do
then I don't have the answers I don't
think there is an answer I don't know
I look at this picture and this is the
worst picture to choose for this yeah it
doesn't make any sense
do they have other pictures here no
because it's like yeah it's a disguise
let's see it looks like he's enjoying
like a Saturday it is a Saturday he's
enjoying his Saturday and Miss said and
drinking his tea what I'm sorry man I
feel like a lot of this part of me wants
to wants to feel like it's just an
excuse for lazy people who demand free
stuff I know it's not everybody I know a
lot of people are really hurting and
struggling any to pay rent and they're
real people but I also know a lot of
urban socialists who are like dude like
why do you even pay rent it's so dumb
like Oh landlords not even a job and
food should be free too and now this
happens and they're like dude I'm not
paying rent it's like do you do you have
the rent money
well some people a lot people get laid
off yeah but did you at least have some
money to pay rent for this month should
they pay it should they pay food I don't
know man
everybody's getting there you know what
I'll tell you I'll tell you all right
now they just approved a stimulus
everybody's getting four months four
months of guaranteed wage from the
federal government pay your rent rent
strike to me sounds like people trying
to exploit the system yeah I agree
the government's gonna give you money
plus twelve hundred bucks pay your rent
right what was that company that isn't
gonna pay their rent no cheese cake
factory factory so yeah that's you don't
think that they have profits from I
totally do and they should pay their
rent yeah I agree
well it's ridiculous that they're not
paying their and the government's doing
a big bailout for for the you know for
everybody so it seems like yeah you got
corporate exploitation right there yeah
exactly
well we're not gonna pay our rent not
this time it's like gtfo I don't know
dude it's it's everything is tied
together it's impossible to know for
sure
like the AP chose this dude who is like
he looks like an urban Lefty and and my
confirmation my my personal bias against
social is socialism communist is like my
alarm bells are ringing you know does is
here yes so I'm not trying to impugn the
honor of this man I don't know who he is
I'm sure he's probably a fine person
fine gentle I just know look I know
people in New York who are squatting and
stuff and I I think they're lazy I
think they're conceited narcissistic
individuals and they one of those people
to do they would break into buildings in
the financial district and then find
vacant like office lofts and then put
their own padlocks on it and then when
the police come can't do anything about
it and so that's what they would do and
I'm like that's so messed up like what
one of my criteria for being a friend is
not being a squatter I feel like the bar
is pretty low I don't know I guess I
don't really know anybody who would
squat I guess I don't have this wider
range I'm solid like I'm surprised a lot
of the squatting laws we have you know
they are pretty crazy so you can go on
vacation and someone can break in your
house yeah what's up with that and then
the cops won't kick them out why
squatting laws what's the idea I think
the biggest the difference of you coming
in and say you're armed and someone's in
your house from that same squatting law
this person's in my house get out of my
house you're my house boom you're not
getting out I felt this in my own house
it's the problem with you squatting
what's the difference though isn't it
feel it feels like the same thing what
you tell the cops I guess is the things
I've read stories from people who say
that like I went on vacation to Europe
for a couple weeks when it came back
some crazy lady was in my house when I
called the police
she claimed she lived there and the cops
wouldn't kick her out and I'm like why
don't you tell the police this woman
just broke into my house and then they
show up be like please get rid of her
and when she screams to my house you can
be like here's my no she's broken here's
the title but what the person does they
go to please and say I don't know I
haven't been here in a few weeks and
then she's like I live here it's my
house and the cops are like civil
dispute you take care of it yeah so what
would happen if you showed up someone's
house in the middle the night broke in
and then just call the police and said
this a strange man in my house and when
the cops showed up he said that guy's
sleeping in that room I don't know who
he is to my house they'd probably arrest
you like I mean they'd probably arrest
like the person who lived there if
someone so actually this is a common
thing and it's one of the most annoying
and broken things with policing in this
in this country in most countries
whoever calls the cops first wins
straight up so it's actually a common a
common thing I don't know if it's common
but it's a technique in in grifting like
legit Street grifting one of the things
you do is that you call the cops on your
mark and have the police seize their
property for you you the use of
authority is a very common thing in in
grifting I don't know the video of us
talking about what happened to Johnny
Depp comes to mind though you know about
the the man versus the female or you
know and well it's always like the girls
always right yeah they always side with
the girl in any sort of dispute in that
sense and it's like that still kind of
holds true though in this situation like
if you can't just be like the guy calls
the cops and they come and the girls
like he's bit he was beating me right
even if it was the truth they'll side
with they're gonna side with her yeah
but it's like so what so one of the
tricks I don't I don't want to say too
much because I might get in trouble but
without going into too much detail about
how some cons work you basically plant
something on a person mmm-hmm and then
call the call the cops on them and then
you can say officer that person has X
that's proof they took it from me right
like so alright I'll just say it one
that one of the women you pretty much
just right so one of the common grips is
reverse a reverse pickpocket right you
take you you wait for someone the
criminals will wait for someone to leave
an ATM and please don't do any this
stuff wait for someone to leave an ATM
and you wait for someone to leave their
their receipt behind because he'll do it
all the time yeah you then see exactly
how much they took out and then you take
a semi empty wallet with your ID in it
and you reverse pickpocket you put it on
them call the police
say I'm following them and when the
police come you can say they've got my
wallet my IDs in it they took $200 cash
the cops will then search them and the
person's gonna back I have no idea were
talking about find the wallet see it may
like we got him and that person's going
to jail because the cops gonna write up
we found the wallet on them and the cash
yeah whoever calls the cops first wins
and grifters weaponized that against so
I don't know how we got on the subject
but yeah it's a serious problem and I
know because I've dealt with it
firsthand when when I was 19
mining my own business at a mall
security guards beat the crap out of me
my brother and then when I tried calling
on when one as they were beating my
brother they took the phone and hung up
and then they called the police and just
lied and the cops came and arrested US
yup
so we're walking through the mall
minding our own business some guys just
grab them from
the grounds are they took his head
bashed in the ground so I'm screaming
like help alright and I took my phone
and I called 911 he grabs my phone from
me they and I don't want answers and
then he presses end and he laughs and he
and he drops my phone my god then they
call the police and say these guys were
threatening people and screaming and the
cops were like you got it and arrested
us and when I said to the to the cop
please get the footage they attacked us
he was like I don't care he's like
literally don't care
weren't it's never get never gonna
happen dude yeah and I said but I called
you guys first he's like I don't I don't
care I literally don't care and then we
got to spend the night in jail
yep and then we got the case dismissed
and the judge was just like you're not
gonna sue him are you and we're like no
your honor he's like fine case dismissed
so it was like we were told basically a
case dismissed all right now I'm gonna
sue them yeah but nobody would touch it
on either because the the case involved
police negligence and none of the local
attorneys wanted to go up against the
police department because they also had
to work with him they were like no we're
not touching this and I'm like so they
just get away with it isn't this a
wonderful world we live in
well there are problems but there are
chances for corruption yeah that way
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you